and one of those obtainable resolutions
i think would be self-care so let's talk
about that the presents are unwrapped
and holidays are almost over but how
about some time to ourselves spa aqua is
here to help
with more tips on how to distress at
home and take care of our skin so
welcome to the show joanie torres thank
you thank you for being here i'm excited
to talk facials because i am in need
okay so introduce us to spa aqua what do
you guys do for the community so we have
a full-service spa and salon we provide
massages facials body treatments massage
hair services manicures and pedicures
and we will have some mail services
coming as well so pretty soon a barber
shop oh good wow okay so something for
everybody so when it comes to skin
especially in las vegas this dry weather
what should we do to take care of our
skin let's go through some tips so one
of the bigger things you want to focus
on is exfoliation because if you never
remove
that dull layer of skin then you cannot
add in those peptides and hydration that
your moisturizers are doing so you're
just defeating that purpose absolutely
how often should you exfoliate you can
start off with one time a week
and then once you work with your
esthetician to get a skin care regimen
they'll make those specific
recommendations for your skin okay
speaking of specific recommendations
what's going on over here so i am
jealous i'm putting on our collagen mask
it's infused with caviar so antioxidants
it has a hydrolyzed collagen so it helps
support that collagen production and
when you start losing collagen you can
always be we're affected by the
environment as well so everything
impacts our skin care right so it's
never too early to start trying to
protect and rebuild your collagen that
is a great tip that's a great tip so and
for glowing skin you know since we're so
dry here what do we need to do to get
that extra glow that moisture look or
that you know that dewy skin here i love
vitamin c i'm a vitamin c junkie are you
a serum girl i'm a big serum okay teach
me please because i've been trying to
figure out this whole serum culture i
don't get it so i need the tips so what
are the serums you use so i have
aluminum luminous c pro okay it's very
hydrating it has the vitamin c inside of
it but just as important as putting that
on my skin is what you eat too so right
those healthy fats like the avocados the
kale the leafy greens because kale has
vitamin c in it as well
starting off with just exfoliating with
that cleanser and then following it with
that vitamin c i do it at night okay um
and that just really helps you walk into
that morning with just really dewy plump
and refreshed good okay so we're gonna
just talk about making an appointment
after this segment okay let's talk about
the products here what you guys have at
the salon you know and how people can
book services so we have our namine
cream it has a time release retinol okay
so that's important for like aging
wrinkle reduction it also has that
vitamin c component so that brightening
tightening lightening that everyone is
searching for and looking for of course
those collagen masks that we're using
right there so it has those caviar
extracts that plumping of the skin do
you guys notice the massage that's
happening while the mask is on this is
premium service okay let's keep going do
not forget your spf because you need
some protection all year round i know
every single day yeah they think like
it's winter time so you don't need those
things but you absolutely need that all
year round
and we are available for services all
year round so you can come in and set up
an appointment
for any of your skincare needs or just a
relaxation so massages exfoliation of
your skin as well so those
sugar scrubs that we offer for our body
treatments are really nice i'm just
making sure that you take care of
yourself always
and being just holistic in that approach
it's always in all ways
i like that i like that's a website for
people to get more information spaaqua
lv.com has all of our information on
there it even has our new menu that
we're launching in january okay well we
keep us posted girl i'm excited